hello everyone
back in december 2021 i had made a video
targeted at jee asperance and after that
video
i had mentioned that i would not be
making any such videos
for the je aspirants
however since j mains is just around the
corner i thought that i'll share a few
quick tips with the je aspirants so
first and foremost
uh you all the jay asperance you have to
remember that in these last few
remaining days whatever time is left
you have to realize that
whatever preparation you have done is
already done
in this last few days
no matter how much effort you put in it
is not going to make much of a
significant difference which is not to
say that i am asking you not to devise
or not not to prepare or not to study
it's not like that but it's not going to
make much of a significant difference
so why am i making this video why am i
trying to share these tips i'm trying to
share these tips just to emphasize that
in these last few days
it is more of a mental game
okay it is a mental game and in this
mental game
your biggest enemy
is you yourself in fact your mind with
its various kinds of negative thoughts
even if you are a very positive person
you are after all a human being flesh
and blood and it is very natural for
such kind of negative thoughts to crop
up even if your preparation is very good
and certainly if your preparation has
not been very good and let me just point
out here that you yourself know very
very well what level of preparation you
are in but irrespective of those of that
preparation level
let me just point out these steps
regarding this mental game so what kind
of negative thoughts most common is that
what will people think if i don't
perform well
okay low key
this is the biggest
demotivating negative toxic thought that
can come up in your brain
regarding this what i can say is don't
give a damn about it okay it is much
easier said than done
but
as you grow older you will realize
that this is the ultimate truth
okay
i'm saying not just
about what others will say in the sense
that what your neighbors or your friends
will say i'm even saying this with
respect to your own brothers and sisters
even to your own parents
okay
do not worry about what others including
all these people will say
ultimately it is just a game between you
and the james the examination questions
okay
and
uh you realize as as you grow older you
will realize that
this kinds of thoughts which especially
comes up and which seems to dominate
your entire psyche especially in your
teenage years as you grow older you will
realize that you are probably
overestimating
the kind of thoughts people have about
you
okay so they think actually much less
about you than you actually think that
they think about you okay so this is a
bunch of words but i hope i make myself
clear
so everyone has their own problems
everyone has their own struggles
they may think about you a little bit
but
in all likelihood you are overestimating
how much they are thinking about you
okay so
just like you do not spend your entire
day thinking about others they are also
not thinking about you so you don't have
to worry on that account and
at the end of the day even if for
argument's sake let's say they are
thinking
what can you do about it it is not in
your hand so why bother okay so take a
very philosophical stand about it the
other negative thought very obvious very
evident that will naturally come to your
mind is that
if you do not perform well what will
happen to your future
well
the philosophical stand to take here is
that at this moment just before the
examination this is not the time to
think about it
okay you will have ample time to think
over it to ruminate over it to
to torture yourself as much as you want
later on after the results are out so
why bother now
right now your entire aim should be to
extract the most out of the preparation
that you have whatever little
preparation you have try to extract the
most out of it this is the crux of the
mental game
okay so
you will see that
many people who may not or or rather
many people who have exactly the same
level of preparation that you have may
be able to perform better than you have
just because they are able to push out
all these kinds of negative thoughts out
of their brain and then
perform absolutely to the best of their
abilities and to the absolute best 100
percent of the potential of their
preparation so you also try try to do
that
the next thing is not
a negative thought but this als
almost always happens especially with
people who are taking who are attending
a big examination like j means for the
first time
because of all the media hype and all
the youtube videos
that they see
it creates
a some sort of a
perverted picture in their mind
regarding the apparent importance of
such an examination they put it up on a
very high pedestal they respect it like
anything they worship the j means so
this kind of an attitude like too much
respect for an examination is actually
detrimental to your ability to actually
perform well in that examination rather
your attitude should be
slightly irreverent okay irreverent
attitude towards the examination i'm not
saying to disrespect it but if you
respect it way too much you will not be
able to perform well with it you'll not
be able to
play it like a game
uh
and
give your best
okay so i hope you uh you understand
what i'm trying to say the next thing
is that
many of you may be thinking
that
if you can somehow get into iit life is
set
nothing can be farther from the truth
okay there are
examples of many students who come to
iit think like that that their life is
set then they goof off take it way too
easy
and then their entire life is ruined
this has happened to many many students
what you should be thinking is that the
opportunity
to study at iit
is not a license is not a privilege to
take it easy and to have musty all the
time of course there will be moments of
fun
like in every college there will be
moments of fun but in but the
opportunity to study in an iit
or in any good institute is actually
what it is really is an opportunity
for you to struggle even more to fight
even harder to get
better results to improve your academic
credentials to uh to go higher and
higher it is an opportunity to fight
even more it is not an opportunity to
just have fun and to goof off
so these are some of the mental things
which i think we should keep in mind
uh in these last few days
but
the most important tip that i have
shared with you i think is that you
should not put it up on a pedestal
worship it
rather play it like a game and you you
see that you will be able to extract the
best out of your preparation no matter
how it is now
so with that with these things i will
just end this video all the very very
best